what's up people time for another movie
retrospective the crafts going witchy on
this yeah another movie grew up with 90s
I was just come out of the Army and they
and I saw this
yeah 1996 this game I was six years out
of high school so I finished college I
was like two years out of the army and
then this came off I think I saw this in
the theater I might have as well now
that I'm like thinking about it yeah it
was good it was pretty cool
yeah it was cool in it I even want to do
this one for a while because even though
I was talking to somebody on YouTube
about I guess like something that I said
when we reviewed event horizon how I
said I wasn't like super crazy about 90s
movies I don't mean like 90s movies in
general I'm just usually I mean like
horror sci-fi movies from the 90s
now this one it has some of the things
that I don't like about 90s movies but
for some reason this one like gets away
with it you know this is one of the only
ones that does I liked in 90s movies uh
they were kind of formulaic yeah in a
way it was kind of comforting you know I
mean yeah that format that they would
give it you know give a movie to you you
know they gave you a movie in a certain
way most of the times yeah it's like a
90s way of doing it which is you know
it's alright it was I don't know
everything just seemed like very slick
yeah
which this movie does as well which I'm
not a big fan of that usually but I
really liked this one just because I
think this might have been the first
time that I saw at least like a big
mainstream movie that had goth girls in
it well no because I'd seen Beetlejuice
that had Lydia that was 88 or 89 um this
is the first one that actually showed
witches or Wiccans in like a fairly
realistic light it didn't just show like
witches is like bad guys it was kind of
like more nuanced than that which I
don't think I'd ever seen in like a big
kind of studio picture before in my
meathead type way I just kind of broke
it down as basically being the same
thing as the jit the the set the Jedi in
the scene which is what it is that's
what it is that's what that's what they
were talking about yeah a Japanese
interpret for interpretation of
is or wizards and you know yeah because
the nice thing about this one is that
even though it's interesting because
this doesn't really have like a proton
protagonist and antagonist type of thing
I mean you could say that firoozeh Box
character becomes like the villain or
the antagonist but she's also still kind
of sympathetic and you can see like how
she ended up going down the path that
she went down it was just kind of like
you know the the way that these four
girls interacted was kind of like you
know witchcraft is real but it's it's
just a power out there that you can use
for good or evil like the power itself
is neutral you know what I mean like a
divorce like the force and so it's
basically kind of like the same thing
and like I said I think this might have
been the first at least the big movie
that had portrayed witchcraft that way
rather than just making them straight up
bad guys last night we were at the club
and was talking to a guy who saw some of
my videos about robots and stuff and
that I brought up the fact that the guy
who wrote these stories going a guy who
was kind of like the Japanese version of
of Stan Lee he was Japanese but he was
in a way kind of like a crypto Christian
and in a way you could kind of interpret
Star Wars as a Japanese type of
Catholicism they had it wasn't so much
Shinto but Buddhism and Catholicism
mixed well his cartoons were kind of
like that too they predated Star Wars it
makes me wonder if maybe Lucas had
scenes or had heard about some gonna got
comic books because they were you know
I've read them so you don't know the
stories yeah because there was that big
East me sweat and eats East meets West
thing and and west meets East they kind
of merge and witches are in there the
way they're kind of the way this is kind
of shown it's a lot like Star Wars to me
you know well yeah like I said and that
seems like a more rational way to look
at things because you know like I said
it's this power that's out there
whether it's witchcraft whether it's the
force whatever you want to call it um it
can be tapped into by people that have
the ability to do that it's also Chi ya
or you know and it can be like used for
either thing and yin-yang the symbol of
Chi it's dark and light yeah and you
know they're kind of like chasing one
another and kind of canceling one
another out you know the light and the
dark
good and evil God the devil that kind of
it's that same motif yeah kind of
universal I guess yeah and I and I like
that this was kind of the first movie to
show that rather than having it be kind
of like a black and white like you know
villain and you know here's this girl
that comes into town and like dude
witches at the villains it's really not
like that it doesn't like judge her for
being a witch because really so um yeah
right hands and everything is it evil
wasn't punished really by an outside
force was it evil punished itself yeah
because what they ended up doing I mean
I'll get into that in a little bit but
it's like you know she kind of ended up
using the power against the person that
was using it for evil so she was using
the same thing yeah and it didn't kill
her or anything like that but yeah so
Robin Tunney played Sarah and she's had
some problems in the past
like she's attempted suicide and various
other things and they have moved to Los
Angeles from San Francisco and they move
into this really big nice slick
Mediterranean looking mansion which is
pretty fantastic I don't know if it's
still there that's an actual mansion
that they shot not the interiors that
was the set but the exterior czar all
and that witchcraft store they go -
that's a real store - yeah which
actually might still be there because
I've seen like photographs of it I don't
know how long ago if it closed or
whatever but so she moves there and at
this school it's a Catholic school but
there's this group of three girls that
everyone kind of like they're not
exactly they're kind of bullied um
they're not exactly like [ __ ] on a lot
but it's like you know I mean they kind
of get whispered about and made fun of
in stuff like that yeah they're just
kind of like these three misfit girls
and you know the the rumor is that there
are witches now the thing about it
that's interesting is that even though
the three of them are witches and
basically doing you know Wiccan
ceremonies even though they don't I
don't think they call it Wicca in the
movie they're never refer to it as
anything yeah they just say they just
call them witches that's all they do
they don't say anything but but it's
interesting to note that there was for
this movie there was a Wiccan like
expert who did like who was a consultant
on the movie and like so a lot of the
invocations and stuff like that they do
I recognize them from like some old
witchcraft books that I used to read so
it's like so it is very accurate even
though the spirit they invoke man on
that's not a real they made that up for
the movie just because ironically they
were afraid they didn't want to like
they want people you know worship well
they didn't want to invoke a real one
just in case like just in case it was
real you know what I mean which I
thought was kind of funny but yeah so
ironically these three girls that are at
this school that are already you know a
coven or whatever they're doing the
ceremonies and everything but they don't
actually have any powers now Sarah the
main character played by Robin Tunney
she does have powers like she has like
natural witchcraft ability which do you
find out later like came from her mom
who I think is dead because when she's
in the classroom and the other one of
the other girls sees her and she's doing
that thing with the pencil where it's
just like standing up and like spinning
around and like going down into the desk
and she's just like doing it like that
and she's doing it like without even
thinking about it so basically what ends
up happening is that the three girls who
were in this coven already they are like
well she's got to be our fourth now
because she's the one with powers so in
a way I don't want to say that they're
using her from the outset because I mean
they did befriend her they did help her
you know so it's not kind of like that
but they did sort of because I was
watching this other review the other day
and and he said you know they're
leeching off her power they didn't have
any but the fact that she came there and
she had powers and then all of a sudden
when they started doing their ceremonies
like [ __ ] started to work yeah like [ __ ]
that they started asking for like
started to really happen yes
about that element or they said they
didn't have any powers until they didn't
they were just pretending that they did
and I was like and I didn't even really
and I've seen this movie like a billion
times and I guess that didn't really
occur to me that they were essentially
like stealing her powers I don't think
they were doing it like in that sort of
way like how that sounds they eventually
got their own powers they were just but
they were channeling hers that's what
I'm thinking well I think she was she
was the only one that had natural powers
it kind of learned there's I think and
though yeah and so they were just doing
the invocations and stuff but I don't
know they don't really go into if [ __ ]
was working for them before she got
there because if you remember the one
character that's played by Neve Campbell
who had had cute as a bug in this one
she really what will they all they all
day all of them are yeah um who had all
this burn scars like all over her back
and she had been apparently she had been
trying to like kind of wish them away
like with the witch again it hadn't been
working it didn't work until Sarah got
there yeah yeah they didn't and and the
powers that they had they didn't really
have any real powerful ones until the
very end of the movie yeah look they
looked kind of dangerous like
what's-her-name the character that
firoozeh played what was named that
character do you remember their just
girl manatee Nancy yeah
Shikha she could cast an oar on herself
to make her look like somebody else yeah
because she at one point she that was
the first thing I saw that I was like
yeah that was the first magic power I
think I remembered that she did was to
be able to do that well what they did
for them no because it really just kind
of built up to that first they were like
just asking for you know kind of nice
stuff you know what I mean although it
must be said that fur is a box character
one of the first things she wished for
was that her abusive stepfather would
drop dead of a heart attack and he did
okay which um that's kind of a pile it's
kind of shitty but it's like he was a
creep and he was like molesting her I
think they imply ahead and then her and
the mom got like a whole bunch of money
and they moved out of the trailer well
yes he had life insurance and she was
and there was plausible deniability
how he died yeah he just died an artist
died of a heart attack so yes it was
time possible deniability no where you
weren't positive yeah but that but it
did happen but it did happen but when
she went like that turned herself into
that other girl I was like oh yeah she
can really well no well they they kind
of like did that at the beginning
because you remember that was like near
the beginning when they were first
starting to hang out and then I think
the first thing that they did was when
they were out in the woods and they did
an invocation in limbo like all the
butterflies came yeah and then that one
guy that was chasing them like I hit by
a car or something like that I think
that might have been the first time when
they were like hey like we did that
because we were trying to run away from
that guy and that a car hit him and we
escaped we rented this or this we
watched this before this was on Netflix
on Netflix or Gary I think it's on
Netflix or shudder yeah you guys should
go watch if you haven't seen it it was a
slick movie now now that we're talking
about it again I mean I saw it a long
time I'm gonna I think I saw it in the
theater it I liked it at the time but
seen it again it was a lot better that I
remembered it but it was a lot more to
it than I remembered I remembered it at
first being kind of simple and fat but
at the time but practice it wasn't
really paying real close attention to it
yeah like you said I didn't realized
that they really didn't have any powers
it kind of started slowly yeah it did
and like I said so they you know they
started doing that and then like when
they were hanging out at one of their
houses and they were doing that light as
a feather stiff as a board thing that I
think every girl ever in America has
done like a slumber party and then Sara
does a glamour where first she changed
her eye color and everybody was like oh
well okay subtle but then she changed
her hair color remember she just like
went like that in there and her hair
changed the CG looks good it held out it
does actually you can tell that that's
like that that was like keyed because
that's how they did like a green skirt
or chroma key or something like that
because ironically if so wasn't CG it
was some kind of yeah well it is kind of
but it's they have to like key it to
different colors because the thing about
it is that Robin Tunney's character you
know Sarah Robin Tunney had just been in
Empire Records which is also a pretty
good movie and she shaved her head
for that so when you sing her in the
craft that's all a wig which I didn't
realize until you see the scene where
she changes where she has the glamour
and changes her hair color you can tell
it's a wig then because it's kind of
like close-up and you know it changes
color but um yeah it didn't occur to me
that that was a way because you don't
like after I saw that I haven't seen
Empire Records in a long time either big
yeah she achieved everybody's good in
the movie I still think four is is the
[ __ ] most striking the one that's
when I remember the most I think that
she's the one everybody remembers
because everybody in this is good um you
know Neff Campbell is great in this this
was the same Koo Skeet Ulrich Ulrich is
in this as well and this was the same
year that both of them were in scream
but um Neve Campbell is good in this
because she is totally believable as a
kind of misfit who is you know cuz she
handled this burn scars so she's really
like insecure about it she even calls
herself a monster at one point and but
she just has like her slumped over
shoulders and she's always wearing like
all these layers and baggy clothes and
like she kind of always has her hair in
her face and stuff but then after she
you know after they do the spell and
they do like the you know and she goes
and has the surgery and all the burn
scars disappear like she comes into the
classroom with like a short-sleeved
shirt on and she looks all pretty and
that ever sent plausible deniability
with that too because she was undergoing
some kind of treatment right when that
happened and the doctors thought that
they did it yeah which they would think
but you I was kind of wasn't 100% sure
one way or the other
I mean you but I guess the wit the movie
clearly tries to spin that as she did it
not the doctors yeah I think they make
it because I thought the implication was
that she had been undergoing these
surgeries cuz I think they even made
some kind of offhand comment bellow oh
maybe it'll work this time or something
like that so she had been doing them
like over and over again it hadn't been
working and you know after just after
they did after Sarah came and they had
like the four of them like all the power
together then [ __ ] started to happen for
them unfortunately for RZA Box character
Nancy she starts taking [ __ ] a little
bit too far now I mean some of the stuff
they do is mean
but understandable like I said Nancy
kind of like given her creepy molesty
stepdad a heart attack you know she
wasn't a bad character that's what I
need that's what's cool about her she's
very she's she's relatable she just kind
of went down the wrong path
she did try she did wish for the death
of her stepdad but that might have been
justified or that might have been that's
what I mean he may be happen and then
later on you know she did seem to be
trying to conduct an attempted murder
she was trying to kill that other girl
yeah she was dead didn't get it done but
you know and then how she ends up in the
I don't want to spoil the movie for
people that haven't seen it but yeah I
think probably most people lives yeah
she ends up in an insane asylum but
that's not necessarily a temporarily and
that's not necessarily permanent a
permanent thing might've been temporary
yeah and I mean some of the things too
like Rochelle the one character who is
you know african-american or mixed-race
she she gets made fun of a lot by this
one like you know [ __ ] blonde bimbo
kind of chick yes cool and so Rochelle
like makes this bitch's hair fall yeah
and I was just kind of like oh well
shouldn't have been such a [ __ ]
maybe that wouldn't have happened to it
yeah it's not a pod that it's permanent
it's just it's just there's a lot worse
[ __ ] she could have done say I thought
first did a great job on the Nancy
character she got the orchid archetypal
[ __ ] goth chick of the 90s that she
looks [ __ ] great and I was hanging
out a Man Ray back at that same time
this is a club in Boston goth club in
Boston not there anymore
but that's a way a lot of them looks
that I don't know I we ran into firoozeh
at the Empire vampire couple I think two
years ago maybe she was right behind me
getting coffee I think I didn't know how
do you know who that was I didn't
recognize her it's weird because I just
we saw her like we were up on a czar
later yeah and I saw her come out of
like the backward when I recognized her
like immediately
bro I think he looks almost exactly this
I didn't recognize her because I expect
her to have black
care and stuff she didn't she have brown
hair yeah it's brown um but I kind of
think the way she played that character
I kind of think maybe she was was a goth
chick in her real life yeah she wasn't
granted 24 she really is one yeah like I
don't see my mother it wasn't a costume
it didn't seem too costumey right that
seemed like something that just that
that's a big thing and maybe that's one
thing that bothers me about some movies
in the 90s is that once the goth thing
kind of started to get more popular and
they started sticking it like in all
these mainstream movies to make him seem
like edgy or cool or whatever it's like
you could tell that a lot of those
actors weren't like that because it's
you they never get it exactly right like
even in Terminator 1 the two punk-rock
guys or three pumpkins right did that's
not the way they looked no it's not the
way they look that look too clean and
too showy and twos it's just it always
really bothers you look like a costume
for God that's what I need and it's like
and it's hard for me to put my finger
exactly on what it is it's just like the
whole closer all to the new there's one
of the things that the clothes looked
too new maybe in terms of punk rockers
yeah closed always looked too new they
always looked a little bit too expensive
things looked a little too bright and
new like you know I mean like you could
tell that that wasn't closed it was worn
on a regular yeah there were they
weren't lived it they weren't lived in
type clothes and it might not have been
I mean if the actor was better you might
be able to pull it off like is these
these are just my regular clothes
instead of like a costume that I got at
spirit Halloween you know cuz I'm
dressing up as a goth or a punk rocker
for Halloween or whatever cuz it's like
I get that vibe they did in the 80s too
because like I said punks were always
like bad guys yeah for some reason and I
never [ __ ] saw any Punk looks like
that you know when I was you know going
to high school in the Michigan era area
you know [ __ ] bill winger was looking
you know he was bill I've got a couple
other guys no they were all the punk
rockers and they just hung out with us
we were kind of like a proto goth slash
yeah a tall guys you know what I mean
that's at that time that's before before
goth was really kind of like a thing in
my life but the punk rock guys were just
like regular dude said automated
they just had a different a different
way of doing things different look and
we like them yeah that's what I mean
actually Rock girls you know we like
that yeah cool and and I think that's
what's kind of cool about um cuz like I
said I had seen you know Beetlejuice in
1988 and Lydia in that movie who played
by a winner and a rider I mean that line
knew some girls that looked like that
that had I mean that was like kind of
full-on yeah if you were going out but
in the United States punk rockers and
Goths were middle class yeah they were
they're medicalize now yeah I know I'm
in England they had probably been too
[ __ ] poor working-class yeah
originally especially in the 70s but you
know now man in the eighties you know
that's middle-class kids they had buddy
yeah so I definitely feel like you know
Nancy in this movie you know her outfits
looked really good and like I said she
didn't look like she was wearing a
costume real goth girl like I'm not
saying that that's what she wore all the
time
but to the club that's what she yeah
it's like she didn't look like she was
trying to be something she wasn't or it
I did hear that she was a Wiccan and
that she was into that kind of [ __ ] so
that may be why yeah you know what I
mean yeah that's going on then - yeah
but you know at the time you know when I
first saw her I was my eyes look Dwayne
it's like yeah that was exactly the kind
of look of the girls that was you know
going to - man right yeah and the cool
thing about it too is that even she had
the cutest teeth yeah yeah kind of like
kind of sharp looking teeth with kind of
a pouty lips or something to stop
firoozeh
she's got a she yeah she's she's
something she might bite you yeah she
was really good and she was in masters
of horror she wasn't one of them called
pick me up I think she was in that one
yeah is I feel like she was I mean I'm
sure she was in a lot of stuff but she
wasn't in enough stuff because in this
movie I mean she is the thing that
everyone remembers from this movie not
only she looked fantastic
but she's just a great character like I
said she ends up kind of going nuts and
like doing bad [ __ ] at the end in real
life she's taller than I thought she was
gonna be yeah she was actually I thought
I was a little bitty I thought she's
like maybe 5 1 or 5 - in real life but
what
I think that's probably reason why I
didn't recognize her she's actually
pretty tall and Dan from what I remember
I don't know maybe she's well I think I
heard she was only five foot four which
is maybe like my hater a little bit like
I'm wearing [ __ ] shoes yeah she must
have been because I was under the
impression when we when we ran into her
that she was more like about 510 hmm
yeah I don't know cuz I was on the
impression we she was standing right
behind me that she was a little tall
yeah maybe she was that this men shoes
yeah I forgot to like when she was a
little kid she was in Return to Oz yes
right I was a good movie man we'll have
to like do that what that was like it
was like scary Shane at to the adorable
little thing yeah she was like I said
and you know I don't know I actually
don't know if she's still acting or
anything like that but I do feel like
she was kind of like the main attraction
this movie everybody else was good in it
to you yeah evidently they're doing
they're doing a part two of this movie
or I thought it was a remake or a reboot
the way I read it innocent was a sequel
to oh maybe it is yeah they're doing a
fish I think it's this year I think it I
think it just started shooting a couple
months ago I may be wrong but that's how
I remembered it I remember just being a
sequel to this with the original cast
but I don't know yeah maybe in fact it
should be said I mean I know this is
like a terrible thing to say but I think
like the main character Sarah who's
played by Robin Tunney is the least
interesting character yeah I think so
too
she's kind of I mean I guess she's kind
of supposed to be because she's supposed
to be just kind of like this girl next
door
normally I think she's the mechanism and
the story to show the other three girls
because the other three girls that do
all the interesting [ __ ] yeah make
people's hair fall out she was doing
Nancy was doing Exorcist type [ __ ]
making [ __ ] furniture fly-ash yeah
yeah and also she did a glamour to make
Sarah think that her parents had died in
a plane crash yeah so you know like she
was so she was able to like put news on
her TV they look like real news that's
right that was a lot about that's kind
of messed up because she was trying to
get her to like commit suicide again
yeah and all she slashed her wrists you
but then like I said you know Sarah uses
her it uses good magic like to
counteract bad magic yeah and so that's
what's so like I said I like that they
didn't be like oh she had to be like her
Christ compels you or anything like that
she was using the same power just like
kind of it it's a good move yeah it is
and it's interesting that it did
actually really well I think it did like
much better than they expected like when
it came out in 1986 it only cost fifteen
million to make and it made 55 million
back which was more than they were
expecting I'd like to see it again
because there was more to it yeah and I
remembered and I really didn't quite
catch every element of the movie that
last time we saw it yeah my minds start
wandering but yeah and like I feel like
over the years it developed such a huge
cult following that I you know I don't
know like but it seems like it was
almost single-handedly single movie Lee
like responsible for some of the kind of
like supernatural stuff that came later
on a particularly charmed of the series
I mean charmed is basically that is this
series Sabrina the Teenage Witch I mean
[ __ ] yeah
even like [ __ ] charmed used love spit
loves cover of The Smiths how soon is
now yeah for the theme and that song was
in this movie yeah so it's like that's
you know lust but lover he was like that
was a Richard Butler from cycle at first
right that's like his side band but yeah
so you can see where like this movie was
like massively influential in the sense
that as I said before this you kind of
had like witches were like villains
whereas after this it was almost kind of
like you saw a lot more movies and a lot
more TV series that showed witchcraft in
a more like balanced kind of light or
where it was kind of like a metaphor for
like feminine power or like women
finding their power which is kind of
what it is in this movie so I feel like
this was kind of like a trendsetter in
that way because there really wasn't
much like that before not that I can
remember offhand um you know what I mean
there might have been but was what was
that one weird [ __ ] what was that
weird George Romero movie that we
watched
the season of the witch yeah that was
kind of like I don't know I was gonna
say that's kind of like was showing a
woman like getting into like witchcraft
and stuff like that but I don't think it
was like I wasn't really Kita's positive
though I don't really like labeling this
some kind of like a feminist empowerment
or think you're a girl power type move
because I kind of like cheapens it if it
makes it seem kind of like cliche I
didn't really ever see it that way to me
it was just a wish story and it just it
was just young women doing what they do
yeah so I didn't really categorize it is
that way you know what I mean is any
kind of famous political angle or agenda
to the thing I didn't really see well I
I'm not saying that as a political thing
I'm just saying that's kind of like and
that's probably how a lot of young women
who watched it I mean that's definitely
how I saw it when I watched it as some
political no not analytical I'm just
saying as now it's like metaphorical for
like okay for like women coming into
their yeah now when you say it our now
that when you say that it brings to mind
a whole new [ __ ] ball game like
what's happening right now but that
really wasn't the deal in the 90s and I
didn't really see the thing as any kind
of political agenda statement it's just
it was just women being who they were I
liked it yeah I did as well and like I
said it's it's kind of cool because the
writer the guy that wrote it and
directed it Andrew Fleming he had been
wanting to make a movie about you know
high school girls on witchcraft and [ __ ]
like that
this is so funny to me I didn't actually
realize at the time this movie is is
rated R which might seem kind of weird
because there's not a lot of gore
there's no nudity or anything like that
in it not even a lot of swearing what
ended up happening was that the writer
director wanted this to be a pg-13 so he
goes to the letter like all the MPAA you
know rules for making a movie and you
know at pg-13 you can only have one you
can only say [ __ ] once you can't have
too much gore you can have this then the
other so he did that
exactly right and then he submitted it
to the MPAA
and the MPA said oh well the fact that
it's about high school girls practicing
witchcraft means that it has to be in
our
there's nothing you can do to change
that oh that and he was like well god
damn it he's like well I would have put
a bunch more stuff and he was like
really bad cuz apparently just that
theme what was enough to get in an
r-rating so it's like it seems very
weird to me because this movie seems
like at Fir a horror movie
it's very tame you know there's some
creepy imagery in it there's let's look
that's bugs and snakes and there's a
little bit of blood but not ever months
I never considered this to be a horror
movie actually it's it not really cause
no not really
now that you called it a horror movie I
was like yeah I guess this is kind of a
horror movie
I kind of thought of it as more like an
adventure movie something you know I
mean kind of like an adventure movie
they had a bunch of women like I was
saying yeah I don't think it's feminist
in the modern terminology that like
feminist intersectional ism and all this
stuff that they had it's not like that
it's it's just showing the way things
really are that women are [ __ ] to
each other and they were getting even
with these other [ __ ] yes some of
these dudes are [ __ ] total pricks and
relying and [ __ ] they expose them it's
just a normal is the way [ __ ] really is
yeah you're not really only if only if
you had witchcraft powers which is
exactly what I mean you know what I mean
when I'm and I was a little bit older
probably than the target audience for
this movie like when it came out cuz I
was already like out of college by this
point but I still like really dug it and
I think even Nancy's character who you
know kind of gets carried away like she
has to kill people at the end but
everything that each of them do like
every decision they make like to use the
power you understand it because to be
honest most of the people that they [ __ ]
over with the spells you know what I
mean cuz that's also because of because
like you said they they tried to get
that PG rating it's still a movie for
all ages if you asked me you young girls
could watch this young guys could watch
this older people would entertain
everybody they don't really make movies
like this anymore
it's kind of like it's like a to me it
was a movie kinda like Star Wars but
about witches yeah or like would be
another good one kind of like there's a
lot of parallels from movies around that
time kind of like Lost Boys but which
isn't yeah instead of an although Lost
Boys was a lot lot more warrior yeah
yeah but kind of like lost boy it's
similar so tom to some what kind of
situation you know I'd be like those two
which was Lost Boys a a horror movie but
it had comedy in it too
yeah this one is not a really moving
yeah this one's not really this one
doesn't have as much comedy in it
there's like some funny lines in it like
you know there is a box very famous you
know with that bus driver saying watch
out for the we're doesn't she says we
are the weirdos mister but it's like you
know there's little funny lines in it
but it's not I would call it like a
comedy The Lost Boys seems like it has a
lot more comedy in it because it has
like the Frog brothers and [ __ ] Corey
Haim being weird like singing in the
bathtub and everything like that so but
you know that that one had a lot more
gore in it this one it seems like this
is kind of like the best of the 90s teen
movies you know what I mean I would put
this up there was scream which came out
the same year and had a couple of the
same actors in it you know where you
know what's a hokey yeah there's a hokey
wasn't wasn't you know it wasn't like
you know real [ __ ] corny or anything
it had a cool slickness to it and it
wasn't really being real trihard II
wasn't trying to shock you or anything
it was just trying to tell you a good
story and I think yeah and that's that
is something it wasn't really and I
guess this is because they had a real
Wiccan that was like on set that was
like telling them how the [ __ ] went and
as I said I pretty sure I've heard four
reason Parker's a Wiccan as well or was
at the time that this was made so they
treated it seriously
but you know what I mean it wasn't like
you said they weren't trying too hard to
like be cool or edgy or anything like
that it just kind of came across as any
other belief system which is what it is
in the town the town of the movie I
thought was
and entertaining realism sometimes
realism isn't entertaining it's kind of
a stylized version of realism yeah even
the special effects and everything look
like when a paranormal event would
happen it would be a plausible
yeah normal video I could see that [ __ ]
happening yes I saw poltergeist you know
some people you don't know don't know I
am it was kind of like I could when you
see a horror movies about poltergeist
man they got the [ __ ] all [ __ ] wrong
no that's not but when I saw the special
effects of this I was like yeah if there
was witches that had powers that's what
that that's what it would look like
because it's not completely Korea wasn't
completely crazy not over-the-top it's
just like oh my hair hair color changed
yeah Wow you know it didn't really host
kind of like buying into the effect -
yeah that's like it's portraying
something that a paranormal event that
could actually happen like that yeah
it's it it didn't even get real nutty
until the end when went then the two of
them were kind of flying around and
there's like poltergeist and Theresa was
making like the house looked like it was
filled with bugs and yeah yeah yeah yeah
but they weren't really there she was
just making her yeah well that was all
plausible making somebody have visions
make us somebody have hallucinations are
spk recurrent spontaneous psychokinesis
that was going on yeah it's all
consistent with poltergeist or
possession cases and you know something
like out of damn carry you know
something like that yeah this is so it
wasn't over the top I was just gonna
like man yeah that's pretty cool yeah
[ __ ] up yeah this is like really do
you know what I found this an
interesting fact I found this on
Wikipedia but apparently they had over
80 actresses that were trying out for
all different four parts they're the
main Martin parts one of whom was
Angelina Jolie hmm she was nobody then
though she was yeah what had she been in
an idea a couple of had she been in a
Girl Interrupted yet she was good in
that I can't remember what year that
came out that might have been 94 I don't
remember I think I saw that the theater
very overrated I mean I liked her
I guess you could say but her beauty is
very overrated like that good
I heard people just go yeah woman so
going over time
you know she's a good-looking woman
but yeah it's just overrated okay like
do you put firoozeh bulken and her next
I think for is it would be cuter than a
reason yeah Dan Angelia Jojo well phrase
Ibaka is kind of more that's kind of
more my type I yeah it's actually cuter
I think just even though
Angelina when she was really young and
some of those what was that one where
she played a kind of little class of
something rather or what was it she was
young she's probably at 18 or 19 she was
pretty cute yeah but you know there's
little skinny [ __ ] you know come on a
little Twiggy women Twiggy women but
yeah I'm pretty sure that this is on
Netflix
I think it's on Netflix at least in the
United States so if you have not seen
the craft from 1996 and you're into
which movies cuz really not a lot of
those and especially ones where you know
Wicca is kind of like taken seriously
and also kind of like a coming-of-age
not really a coming-of-age story but
kind of like a female coming female
power type of movie if you want to see
that now you turn off all the guys no
it's a good movie it's like if you like
Lost Boys you'd like it hey look women
have to watch it with men in it all the
time y'all can watch some [ __ ] with
women I don't see it but I don't see it
as any different in the other book I
thought was cool because they had the
women you know yeah sometimes if you say
well it's upcoming in a moment in power
like oh man this just come [ __ ] suck
it's not right it's not it's not like
it's not like it's cool it's bad it's
good yeah it's good
like I said they do all kind of cool
[ __ ] yeah killing people and make their
hair fall yeah I love it
purposes fingers the snakes is part of
Lost Boys yeah I'm a vampire movie but
yeah no that would actually make a
really good double feature now that I'm
thinking of it so yeah like I said I'm
pretty sure it's on Netflix if you want
to check it out it's the craft from 1996
we'll see you next time bye